what up reject Nation we are here today to
watch from our friend poor heavy spoilers
classic The Last of Us episode 8 Easter eggs
and breakdown and you know there's some goodies
I'm looking forward to the thoughts that he
has on this one joined of course by Jew number
one at the channel there's Roxy and Michael
hey you're number one manishma what don't
speak the devil's tongue in my household acor
7-Eleven thanks buddy thank you for that introduction
I'm uh I might be a little bit sad on this
episode I still haven't gotten over kallus
from uh this last episode but um we'll see
how I do let's we'll see that's uh that's
the horse I know there's always good reaction
energy right here anyway guys uh leave a like
that would be very much appreciated I love
when you leave a like hey hey guess what guys
[Music] the other ones in the washer right
now the one you should get from shopzeredition.com
but you know what keeps me afloat the fuel
as I call them God fuel that's what the G
stands for in G fuel I'm assuming you use
special promo code reject Nation Link in the
description box get yourself some G fuel today
over there what do you see over there Richard
that's a lot of God fuel that's a lot of God
fuel that's been drank for a lot of late night
editing sessions and boy does it keep this
channel afloat let's get to it
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm your
host Paul in this video we're breaking down
episode 8 of The Last of Us this is the one
I've been waiting for and David in the games
one of the most memorable characters that
you come across when playing David voiced
by Nolan North he started off as an apparent
Ally but as you begin to learn more about
him you start to see his more Sinister side
no blood as quick as in the infected were
terrifying I think one of the scariest things
for me was playing as Ellie and moving about
the restaurant as he walks through a terrifying
machete that level in the game it's terrifying
so hard for me to figure out how to beat this
and I'm like I don't get it I can kill bloaters
and all these other people but this one dude
is taking me forever to be oh yeah because
if you step on the glass or you have to listen
to him and then sometimes the listen mode
doesn't isn't it very accurate it's just no
it's a terrifying love but I like it because
it makes you not feel Invincible which most
of the game depending on what difficulty level
you are playing on most of the game can you
can feel like an invincible character so I
actually liked in that moment it's bogged
down to no you're not invincible like you
can die and I died several times on that part
I play on very easy with cheat codes by the
way it's still hard normally Boss characters
and games are gigantic monsters or highly
scaled characters there was just something
so unnerving about a creepy 50 year old cannibal
walking around looking for you now as is with
all Last of Us episodes the fact that we aren't
playing the game means that they can show
things from the perspective of others in the
PlayStation counterpart you are locked to
the POV of Joel and Ali Raz here we can see
more of David's backstory that's how we begin
as well and we open by looking over his town
which is called Silver Lake in both the shown
game we discover David has taken and upon
himself to become a holy man and over the
top of this we hear him narrating Revelation
21. his opening line discusses the new Heaven
and new earth and this very much reflects
the new world that they've found themselves
in the midst of the verses in this chapter
talk about how there'll be no need for a physical
temple in this new world because God's presence
will be everywhere the Jewish that's from
the Bible I was actually thinking my I'm gonna
get a joke right here it's not a joke that
is from the Bible I'm talking about the real
God okay I'll have to read it sometime we
then jumped to see him hitched up in Todd's
Steakhouse to watch him delivering a sermon
Todd's restaurant was what it was called in
the game and it's been transformed into a
makeshift church we see how people have tried
to find reason in what's happened to the world
and you can totally understand why someone
turned to religion I didn't want to spoil
this episode all the way back in the first
entry but it's even possible that Mrs Adler
could have foreshadowed people going like
this well that's true every day isn't it people
out there need to get right with Jesus now
religion Beyond things ah yes also acts as
a way to explain things for example thousands
of years ago people didn't understand how
the world was formed but religions gave these
answers whilst also outlining the best ways
to live thus people flock towards them because
science hadn't given Alternatives I'm trying
to explain this as best as possible as I can
without offending people what I'm trying to
say is that in this once more stripped back
world you can see why people would end up
becoming religious a lot of people don't have
the scientific tools to answer things and
those preachers could provide the answers
and compared to those that feel lost yeah
no it makes a lot of sense to me that people
would become spiritual in a sense like this
because of the fact that when you're feeling
so hopeless sometimes you will look to something
to find that sense of hope and I'm not saying
that if you are religious all jokes aside
with your Judaism I would understand someone
wanting to I could see both sides of the coin
here so I'm going there's clearly no God look
at the world we live in or no there has to
be a caucus there has to be something good
after all this has passed right yeah but I
also like the way David explained in the episode
I mean was done methodically and very Sinister
the way he talked about how he didn't believe
in God it wasn't until you know the outbreak
and and the quarter steps uh brain infection
started that now he started believing and
it was it's just a very more Sinister take
on it and I actually thought it was really
executed really oh well so I I liked his uh
explanation it was kind of messed up the way
he explained it but I I thought it like worked
well for the character a Revelations is about
the end of the world and this it's easy to
see why so many people attend to this and
David after the world had ended it hasn't
been all sunshine and rainbows though and
Judah longhold Winters David has had to resort
to cannibalism in order to keep people alive
you see a sign hanging up saying when we are
in need he shall provide and this is playing
on Philippians 4 19 which states God will
provide for people I knew it said in the reaction
I think that was a Philippians quote because
there's some quotes I knew because I always
thought it said Philippines when I was growing
up and for some reason that's stood out to
me it's not exactly the same thing but I was
like I think it's a Philippines quote Pinoy
Pride even though it's not Pinoy but Pinoy
Pride his sign is also pulled over to the
game and when Ellie fights David in a restaurant
you see the sign hanging up at the back of
the room oh he's had to cross the line in
order to provide but David's hiddenness from
the people whereas in the game I always kind
of got the impression that the town smoke
were aware yeah now you might be wondering
why they don't just move somewhere warm well
the fact is that people here feel safe and
they very much control our society they're
not oppressed by Federer and the in fact it
also tended to stick to warmer areas though
you didn't counter some in the snow when you
first met David the second game showed the
exposure to the elements left them completely
Frozen you also discovered that every time
they bunker Dan the writers eventually showed
up and thus they had to find somewhere that
wasn't too appealing to others so Salt Lake
is probably the best place to be though the
cruel Winters have meant that food becomes
scarce now interesting little tidbit for you
mate did you know that Viking things called
it Iceland because it would put Invaders off
from going there they called Greenland that
because it was covered in ice and thus when
Invaders arrived there they'd be like sake
anyway he goes after pain God will make it
so there's no more sorrow we learn this girl
has just lost her father and that they want
to bury him but the ground is too cold David
calls himself a father and it's very much
a perverted version of the dad and daughter
relationship that Joel has with Ellie where
as Joel will do anything to protect Ellie
David smacks her in front of people and they're
very much surrogate fathers at opposite ends
of the scale anyway I'm getting the word
Notch yes David is one of them and I think
that's what made the character in the game
so creepy I think this is obviously commenting
on controversies surrounding the church and
gonna be difficult not to offend people but
it's definitely an important thing to address
the entire holy man thing with David is something
I wasn't present in the game and I think it
adds a whole new dimension to him when he's
This creepy religious figure that eats people
and prays on children at this point we get
a quick cut of his right hand man James and
in case you don't recognize him that's Troy
Baker who he actually played Joe in the game
and beggar gave his seminal performance I
think actually helped out with a lot of the
success of the last of us he's a very beloved
voice actor he's played lots of different
iconic characters and I have to say that I
think he completely knocked it out the park
the funny thing is seeing Troy Baker here
it made me go could have played like I love
what Pedro Pascal's doing but he could have
played the live-action version of Joel like
he looks enough like if they want to do a
little bit more of an accurate fiction yeah
I mean it will be extremely accurate for this
try Baker but he looks enough like the game
counterpart and what they did with the model
of Joel I agree with you and before Pedro
Pascal was cast and obviously I never thought
they would actually cast Troy Baker I always
had in my head I I thought Josh Brolin could
do an interesting job as uh as Joel but I
mean because I'd only been exposed to listening
to Troy Baker in video games from Batman Arkham
Origins as the Joker to obviously The Last
of Us Parts one and two and many others he's
got extreme range when it comes to acting
but seeing him actually in live action what
he was able to do in this episode is James
I'm like holy crap he's actually a good live-action
actor too like I definitely could have seen
him as Joel but having said that I freaking
loved Pedro Pascal he's so damn good it's
so damn good so far on the show we've had
Marlene's voice actor playing her in the series
Tommy's popped up as Perry now Baker is playing
Ashley Johnson next left is Ellie's Ashley
Johnson so I can imagine that she'll be popping
up next for the finale the raw rumors about
who she could be playing let's explain them
Baker actually looks a lot like Childers in
the game and I as much as I love Pedro I wouldn't
have minded him playing him in a live action
too look I'm not trying to offend people again
and outside we hear how dire of a situation
they're in when it comes to rations in the
game we never saw this side of things and
after Joel fell off his horse at the University
he then cut to Ali hunting and whilst you
were doing this he noticed the bark that he
then shot an arrow in this didn't kill it
unless he tracked it through the environment
trying to take it out for food it fled to
an abandoned Factory which is when you found
it dead now at this point James and David
step forward now here we see the other side
of it with James and David talking about how
some their spotters saw a deer the other day
you see how their paths now cross from both
sides and also explore the doubt within James
he's clearly wrestling with the fact that
they're crossing the line in order to keep
going and adds a lot of complexity to the
character that wasn't originally there absolutely
it was pretty much just an NPC with a couple
of lines out so we get much more of his thoughts
I thought what they did with James vastly
improved upon a character that just felt like
a nothing character in the in the actual video
game and it adds more to the real world qualities
of having a cult-like leader here because
you got to have at least someone who is in
this realm of feeling doubtful of of the path
that they're on and it helps just humanize
and flesh out the entire experience of this
cult that has essentially formed here so I
thought like what they did with Troy Baker
never distracted from the main storyline and
it didn't feel like it needed to become more
fleshed out or more of a focus it was just
enough to enhance the experience in the video
game again there was that one moment where
he asked James to go get you know the penicillin
and the syringe for Ellie and you could see
like the doubt like well I don't know like
I'm not gonna go get it so they touched a
little bit upon him but it was expanded upon
so much more in this episode he was a lot
more of a three-dimensional character here
and I actually like that because position
that they put him in because again if you
hadn't played the game you're just the general
going audience and you didn't know what was
going to happen later on in the episode which
obviously if you played the game you know
but I like that it kind of created a rift
between them and like oh my God I I kept thinking
in my head okay I know what happens but it
really feels like David at any second could
shoot him or he could shoot David if I didn't
know it was already gonna happen I thought
they did a great job of just adding that that
layer to it between the two characters and
this cannibalism in the snow could be a reference
to the Donna party who are a group of American
Pioneers who migrated to California from the
Midwest they got stuck in a snowy mountain
range for a while and had to resort to cannibalism
like what we see yeah James is starting to
doubt whether this is God's way and it's possible
he knows about the other stuff too in the
game when Joe ambushes the town you overhearsome
saying that David's leadership should be put
to a vote again so this sentiment was clearly
felt among some of the other inhabitants in
the game I don't remember that one I don't
know yeah but you did hear a woman saying
that they were moving the children to a shelter
now in the game James the children okay evidently
waited for him which is when they were both
sworn by infected you had to make your way
that's my favorite scene in the show I made
your final stand against some Runners clickers
in a blowder in the game you had no idea what
was up with David at this point and it allowed
you to build some camaraderie with him so
absolutely no he'd forward lots of hunters
the the people that you'd met in cut scenes
had ended up becoming your allies this was
the case with Marlene Henry and Sam and of
course Joel's brother Tommy it sort of lured
you into this false sense of security with
him and when listening to the kind of funny
podcast a couple of weeks ago it did bring
up a point that stuck with me since then they
said that Kathleen might have even heard that
David reveal a bear because we'd already experienced
an evil leader figure though I don't know
if that's fully the case I do think having
two characters like this in the show hurt
the fact that David was someone you came across
who was worse than the infected you don't
really trust him from the Star whereas in
the game you kind of did yeah and I kind of
feel and missed that gut Punchy bear let me
know below if it caught you off God I'm weirdly
not that bothered by it it's weird how they
like kind of changed they added this Kathleen
character and then they change parts of the
thing with David and the person who died in
their camp that feel like they're in support
and slash setup or what's to come in The Last
of Us Part Two I mean I thought David was
suspicious in in the game right away then
that fight scene is more than just a fight
scene it it builds a trust it makes that speech
later on make more sense for when David is
trying to court her to be his Queen first
of all for people saying hey stop comparing
into the game it's it's called the last just
to say something really quick about that it's
much more challenging to for for some people
sometimes it happens to me with the show to
not compare it to the game because of the
fact that it's not like doing a book where
a book is just a narrated text whereas here
there's so many visual medium parallels that
are adapting it that you're you're more likely
to go wow and in the game they look like human
beings too so you're more likely to compare
there's so much storytelling that goes on
in this action sequence like again you get
that false sense of oh David might actually
be a friendly he had that gun in his and again
this is the the game I'm talking about but
he had that gun the entire time and he gave
Ellie his rifle he could have shot her at
any time that he wanted to but he didn't it
just adds so much more layers to it that was
actually one of the very rare times in this
show where something was cut out that that
personally bothered me sorry to you people
that in the don't compare camp now back with
Ali we see she now says Joe the surroundings
here are identical to the game with him being
on a dirty mattress with a couple of blankets
to keep him warm we had a shot similar to
the game where she examines his wound and
this is something she did Upon returning from
David seeing how little food they have left
I did go back and forth over what the intention
of this scene was she does hold a snap of
it for a second and I even thought that she
might be wondering whether it's worth giving
it to him due to him being so close to that
store I don't think that's what was intended
and I'm sure that the HBO podcast will probably
clear this up we do these videos before that's
released so I don't really get to hear things
people yeah some people genuinely think are
watching our long episode and listen to a
40-minute podcast and then make a 30 to 40
minute video and release it this if only you
could if only you just could we've been using
time travel dude out now but like I said I
don't think that's the intention and Nelly
decides to mount up and go hunting yeah she
comes across a rabbit like in the game and
I have to play this clip again sorry that's
the cutest [__] thing I've ever seen in
my entire life
look I'm a vegetarian yet but still it's a
good reaction unlike the PlayStation counterpart
Ellie's pretty useless or as she was taking
out animals with ease and that we see here
how she's really struggling well she's struggling
in the game there's a three month time Jump
or something right yeah so she has time to
like develop her skills yeah yeah not really
a time Jump battle maybe a couple days right
yeah sometimes you never know what these shows
are like no there was like a three-month time
yeah and also too I forgot to mention too
in that scene that they cut out the that amazing
action sequence David specifically said to
Ellie it's a four mile hike now I don't know
if that was he was just lying that it was
four miles so we're gonna be here a while
and then they move the deer in but I don't
know how long the passage of time was in that
scene but it was a pretty quick conversation
where he reveals what happens and then James
is immediately back so if that really again
I know this is nitpicking but if it really
was four miles because you cut that action
sequence now you put yourself in a little
hole there and you got Dum Dum Dums like me
on the Internet or now making claims about
hey it doesn't really fit there I didn't realize
how much you hate this show this Punchy comes
across the deer and similar to the game she
fails to down it we have a moment mirroring
the sniper scene from episode 6 and I did
appreciate how they built off the back of
that yeah David and James come across it and
he does the typical religious preacher strategy
okay all I ask is 10 seconds of your time
I just I won't say it twice let's see how
these scenes play alongside those in the game
My Favorites [Music]
that's what they were missing from the episode
the bone arrow who's there
now
hello we just want to talk any sudden moves
and I put one right between your eyes and
he shot him moves I put them right between
your eyes do you know for Buddy Boy ditto
for Buddy Boy over there what do you want
name's David this here's my friend James we're
from a larger group women children and we're
all very very hungry from a larger group women
children they're all very very hungry so am
I women and children all very hungry too well
even so you can't drag this back on your own
huh maybe we could trade you for some of that
meat there what do you need you're not asking
for charity we we can trade you for some of
the deer we have what do you need we have
medicine weapons ammo clothes medicine
you have any antibiotics like for infections
we do the camp welcome to follow I'm not following
you anywhere we do back in our village you're
welcome to follow us I'm not following you
anywhere change it he comes back with what
I need the deer is all yours buddy boy can
go get it he comes back you get half the deer
anyone else shows up you put one right between
my eyes that's right anyone else shows up
right between my eyes that's right two bottles
of the penicillin in a syringe make it fast
go on yeah he's questioning him already we've
got two bottles and a syringe it's not code
James do as I said
I'll take that rifle David looks so creepy
to get
now David is well aware of who Ellie is at
this point and as we later learn it was his
men that went to the university either way
they go into one of the Huts which is similar
to how they camped up in the game here we
learn a bit more about David and discover
that he was a maths teacher who converted
to become a preacher after the world fell
apart not even gonna go down the rabbit hole
with avoiding that but we do learn that he
came from Pittsburgh the cusey there fell
in 2017 due to a war between the fireflies
in Federer which is something that was sort
of touched upon in the game in the show Ali
and Joe went to Kansas City whereas in the
source material that was Pittsburgh where
the whole Henry and something happened you
arrived there to find it overrun by Bandits
and could piece together enough things to
learn about what happened Pedra had been keeping
rations for themselves and starving people
and when they were ousted the bandits froze
up in their place people like David ended
up leaving and they run into the same problem
when it comes to food the dialogue in the
scene starts to transform into how it plays
out in the game you know you really shouldn't
be out here
I don't like company you know you really shouldn't
be out here all on your own from where I'm
sitting you shouldn't be at her on your own
I see what's your name why fair enough so
what's your name
look I understand it's not easy to trust a
couple of strangers it's hard to trust strangers
I know but I honestly mean you no harm say
we like a pretty good team it's after we get
lucky oh you look how to run up sooner or
later look lucky no no such thing as luck
you see I believe and everything happens for
a reason no such thing as love no I I believe
everything happens for a reason this winner
has been especially cruel we didn't expect
this winner to be so cruel nothing will grow
game's been hard to find because of the fact
that they really leaned into David being a
preacher his delivery sounds like that like
he sounds like he's talking to his his sheep
like even when he's talking to Ellie it sounds
like he's preaching in a way like there's
that that delivery and Cadence in the show
itself whereas it doesn't sound that way at
all in the game what's a preacher it's a thing
that smart people follow oh and that there's
a select group of people who don't follow
oh okay because they don't recognize Who The
Real Son of God I do agree with you and again
because we had not seen anything from David's
perspective before in the video game again
he's just a suspicious fellow who after an
action sequence now we've built some trust
and camaraderie between the two of them you
don't really have like some basis of background
of why he's speaking the way he does but yes
I agree with you it plays a lot more into
the scene and makes a lot more sense with
given the background that we have of him so
uh what are you doing this Sunday do you have
a place I should go visit yeah a synagogue
maybe oh no no those are on Saturdays I think
Friday night I'm not I'm not the best you
but I believe no we'll head up the other Jews
see when you're supposed to go a few weeks
back I am sent a group of men out nearby Town
look for food so I sent four of our people
to a nearby town to to scavenge what they
could only a few came back and only three
of them came back you said that the others
had been slaughtered I uh crazy man turns
out he was murdered by this crazy man I get
this he's a crazy man traveling a little girl
and get this that crazy man was traveling
with a little girl
you see everything happens for a reason you
see everything happens for a reason
a gun he's the one that killed Alec and she
she didn't kill anybody lower the gun now
give her the medicine
you know this won't be happy about this did
you bring the medicine out yeah throw it to
her David well the [__] out of the way
love you Ashley Johnson won't survive long
out there [Music] I can't protect you you
won't survive for long out there I can protect
you oh thanks [Music] you know after that
shot that they had of of Troy Baker am I completely
missing this guy's career has he not done
a lot of live action works so mesmerizing
in every frame he has and like we didn't even
recognize him right away it took a second
for me to recognize him for sure yeah you
had to point out that I was like oh yeah that
is him I'm obviously not that familiar with
like the face of Troy I've seen him of course
but you had to point him out for me to be
like oh yeah that's him but he's so captivating
in every frame he has here so it's not some
Nostalgia thing for Troy Baker that I have
when watching him there's so much performance
in his eyes alone yeah I'm like what why is
he only mainly known for voice over work when
he clearly is a phenomenal like live action
actor as well his voice is synonymous with
video games he's legendary I mean anyone who's
played any of the video games that he's voiced
of you know that so I think that is maybe
cut into his live-action career because I
agree with you like he really surprised me
in this episode I was watching I'm like freaking
really good why are you doing more live action
it's just the role of James yeah I mean every
time the camera's on him he's really like
I'm pulled in yeah for sure I do miss in the
game like how Sinister the surrounding atmosphere
is with the lighting of how dark it is and
then you see how David just is evolving into
the monster with like the way the fire and
Shadow is casting a specific kind of lighting
over him it feels a little bit more like something
demonic in a way I remember experiencing this
for the first time and my stomach dropped
with the turn this was a guy he just bought
side by side with and had now inadvertently
revealed yourself as being one of the people
that caused this town so much torment now
they've added in a layer where the person
Joe killed being the father of the girl at
the steakhouse and they of course are supposed
to reflect Joe and Ellie we see how the stories
have changed too which y'all being described
as a crazy man whereas we know from our side
that attack them in the game we we never saw
David and James's side after the conversation
but here we can see the doubting him resurfaced
once more as David lets her go now we return
back to the house and again see things play
out similar to how they do in the game
Joel
I I just can't take how good the PS5 Graphics
are it's insane [Music]
here we go yo where the [__] do I put
this
such a good actress
[Music] oh thank you for cutting that up
you're gonna make it
[Music] I love I love that moment so much
[Music] originally this was the moment that
you learned Joel was alive and he'd had a
large part of the game his Ali where he had
no idea what his fate was similar to the game
Ellie lies down with him and whereas in that
we could at the morning to see David's forces
coming in here we cut to the town there's
a lot of focus given to the meat with people
clearly knowing what's going on so they keep
it to themselves because the truth's too difficult
sweet it's hard venison but whether that's
actually true or not is another thing entirely
James does talk about supplies earlier in
the episode but we know from their interactions
that they use code with each other they could
all be lying to themselves keeping their mind
off it and it can mirror the predatory behavior
with David but let me know what you think
below at this point David and James arrived
with the deer and you could say that like
David James because they saved bit of an English
joke there and David admits that they've found
who killed alecially slapping his daughter
when she suggests killing them shows just
how abusive that he is and he tells the girl
that he's her father the now entire town sits
in silence and allows it to happen I think
it very much shows the grip that he has over
everyone when things come out about figures
like this you'll often hear about how many
people were aware of what was going on but
they turned a blind eye to it it's very much
the idea that you don't have to deal with
something if you ignorant to it and no matter
how horrific it is you can reassure yourself
that everything is okay the reason I question
this venison is because this could very much
be carried over to the food too and we get
a lot of focus on the town's people wolfing
it down these are happy to just talk into
their food have a warm meal and be quiet because
speaking UPS better than starving I would
then jump back to Ellie and see as Joe looks
slightly better was it the dad that they they
don't clarify do that they feel like clarifying
but I mean the body's what turn to bones and
I I don't know how long there is that line
in there earlier in the episode when he says
that we we have to wait to bury your dad yeah
so I gotta Matt I I have to imagine that's
what it is which is poetic and disgusting
at the same time I think it's all awesome
next time I come over we're gonna eat someone
dude this is YouTube they specifically say
cannibalism is demons
we won't do that great she injects him once
more and we get a slight differentiation from
the game mazeli gets to go outside whereas
in the game she spotted people coming in from
the basement we get a great scene with David
and James with the former clearly wanting
to take care even though it will only cause
problems with people back in their Community
David wants to spare her because he has ulterior
motives whereas James sees it as being God's
will that they should leave her to die this
very much reflects Kathleen from earlier in
the season who believed it was Sam's Fate
To Die instead of getting the leukemia medicine
either way in both versions Ali decides to
head out and draw them away with us getting
a big action scene Ellie leaves Joe with a
knife and this is what he later uses to interrogate
the people with in the game Ellie took her
horse and Road through the streets as the
hunter slept out to grab her and eventually
the horse was shot and she fell down a Cliffside
she then navigated the surroundings and got
into a hotel which is where she tried to escape
Yoshi stealthily took out hunters and eventually
was grabbed by David which is when she was
transported at the camp yeah they keep the
sort of energy the same but shorten things
a bit with a writing out and the horse getting
shot by James David demands that Ellie has
taken and alive and I did find it interesting
how he mirrors Kathleen a need for Revenge
led to him making dumb decisions and David's
need to have Ali leads to him doing the same
thing he stops Sally from being shot and even
carries her away similar to how giol carried
Sarah at the start of the Season yeah is pretty
much a reverse Joel and he's arguably the
most dangerous person we encounter in the
whole show now it's uh that's outside of one
of your characters but moving on I'm in the
game one Sally's captured we then switch perspectives
to see Joe like what we get here when he first
took control you're stumbling in about and
a little boy's for where which it is like
how he appears here too attention from the
scene comes from the fact that Joel is almost
out of it but he manages to get the upper
hand and take down David's men now the death
scene here is terrifying with a lot of the
struggles feeling like they're ripped right
out of the game the facial expressions especially
are something that I always spin the camera
around to see and I get I guess we've discovered
that I'm a bit of a psychopath but please
subscribe and from here we get the interrogation
scene I was so happy seeing this playing out
as I was thinking that the scene with graham
green was gonna be the show's version of it
might have spoiled a scene for you if you
watched our breakdown for that episode but
I genuinely thought that's how they were going
to play it the Disney the Disney interrogation
was how I thought they were are gonna play
this scene now because they're so similar
you might be asking why have they done something
that's basically the same scene as that well
it's for a good reason as yeah we're seeing
the true side of gel when Ellie's not around
in the cabin we knew nothing was gonna happen
as did the couple because there was a little
girl here they were likely aware Joel wouldn't
do anything which is why they ended up laughing
yeah though giola is free to do what he wants
and he'll do whatever he wants to get Ali
back now let's play the scenes from the game
let's show you how Stuff lines up so much
leave him alone
please I don't know any girl is she alive
what girl I don't know no girl
oh Jesus
[__] Focus right here right here not popping
goddamn knee off you focused wrap up your
[__] kneecap off oh he's so good it's
a girl
she's alive it's too long where where [Applause]
in the town ah the town what town Silver Lake
now you're gonna mark it on the map you're
gonna point to where we are and where your
Resort is and it better be the same exact
spot your buddy points to and it better be
the exact same spot your buddy points to Market
it's right there you can verify it go ask
him go ask him he'll tell you I'm not lying
I ain't telling you [__] okay no I believe
him no
I love the smile on Joel's face it's all right
I believe it you also get a follow-up from
this with Ellie and a moment that builds upon
the original
I know you're hungry been out for quite some
time
although in the game she does eat it dear
dear what it's worth this is just dear meat
I swear it's just the deer meat
you're a [__] animal you're gonna chop
me up into little pieces so now what
you're gonna chop me up into tiny pieces I'd
rather not I'd rather not please just tell
me your name please tell me your name
you're so full of [__] if you want to
judge me judge you [Music] I quit the judgment
considering you and your friend killed how
many men the only way I'm going to be able
to convince the others
around you have heart you're loyal
and you're special you're smart loyal
oh in the life we could build
okay
[Music]
oh [__] you stupid little girl yeah what
am I supposed to tell the others now you'd
see when I go tell the others now oh I love
it Ellie what Ally what tell them that Ellie
is the little girl tell them that Ellie is
a little girl who broke her [__] finger
I
broke your [__] finger
how did you put it huh tiny pieces how did
you put it tiny little pieces Ellie realizing
that cannonballs is so chilling because they
mistake and it was a mistake getting Ellie
caged like this this picturesque Last Resort
on the world has turned into something where
people have turned to cannibalism as a last
resort and what did the frustrated cannibal
do
David recognizes the violent Hall with an
alley and he even talks about how cordyceps
showed him the truth of the world it feeds
and protects his children and he thinks that
it actually loves I realize at this point
that the religion things are charad and that
he lets others believe it because it brings
them Comfort however it also brings people
closer to him and though he won't admit it
it allows him to be propped up and the cordyceps
loving is something that the show's creditors
have talked about on the podcast and even
said that they had the kiss with Tess to hammer
harm this idea love is a lace throughout every
aspect of the show and we've seen both the
positives and negatives of it you have people
like Bill and Frank and the couplin episode
6 but then you have people like Kathleen and
geol who it just causes pain for David has
a sick and twisted kind of love and when he's
assaulting Ellie later on he creepily says
don't be afraid that there's no fear in love
now the cordyceps are very much made him believe
that his sick and twisted be of the world
is the right one and it's a chilling way to
portray the character although his plan with
Ali fails it's likely that he would have got
her into the camp had things not gonna lie
everyone was just silent about him I doubt
they would have spoken up and thus he probably
could have got her as one of the members taking
out chill would have helped him because he
was the only person defending him and a dahlia
the villagers would have been like yeah Ellie's
my friend especially after this stuff for
the University thus early would have been
alone and what people tend to do in abusive
relationships is that they get people away
from their friends and family thus they have
no one to fall back on and with his safety
gun they can fully manipulate the person and
control every aspect of their life the only
aspect you get in the game of seeing David
as the leader of them is the fact that he's
out there on the hunt with them and here you
get a lot more of the actual psychological
manipulation and how people respond to him
back at their village where you can see this
guy knows how to use the power of God to make
himself it's like in a way he views himself
as a God in this situation you know he even
has a line in there I think at some point
about you know they'll do whatever I want
I want them to do you know he he views it
like by being the messenger for God he views
himself as the actual God in this situation
I thought in the game he was written so freaking
well and obviously Noah North did a fantastic
job right but I kept thinking in the game
like why are they listening to him why are
they following him because we obviously we're
not getting to see the perspective from their
side actually watching it from here in the
way it's expanded upon this episode I'm like
okay now I understand why they are following
David why they fear for David the manipulation
he invokes on them how he just views them
as His sheep and he's the shepherd and all
them like this makes so much more sense now
it gives more context to the game even even
though you don't have that stuff in the game
it just gives context and that's the kind
of stuff that I love like when you do adaptations
of video games or whatever and you give that
that other stuff that was not uh expanded
upon and it just like adds gaps there now
back with Joe we see as the storm rolls in
and he makes his way to Salt Lake this is
a similar thing to the game and at this point
you're able to mask your movements by using
the environment now inside a Hut there he
discovers belongings and bodies hanging up
which is similar to what happens when you
enter one in the game yeah he's backpack which
is ripped right out of it too and he realizes
just how much trouble she's in the episode
in general it reminded me a lot of the movie
the road and which characters also come across
cannibals in that also it's important to bear
in mind that James is comfortable doing this
with the chopping board probably because he's
helped David kill people like this before
in the game he even refers to Alias David's
new pad showing how he views her and we then
get at least Escape in another scene that's
ripped right out of the game wakey wakey
I was so smart
I wore you [Music]
had your chance
I'm excited really
so are you
really so are you roll on my sleeve look at
it
right there it's always
look at it I'll play along I'll play along
what'd you say what did you say
I love the reactions everything happens for
a reason right
what the hell is that now she would have turned
by now this isn't real she would have turned
by now it can't be real looks pretty [__]
real to me
[Music]
I might be asking whether Ellie buying someone
can actually infect them and there's a bit
in the second game that clears this up I'll
talk about that in the super spoiler section
section but we do kind of know the answer
to it either way they cut the sections down
here and compress the scene so that Ellie
goes immediately into the restaurant in the
game he made your way through the town and
jumped back and forth between Joel and Ellie
I think it's actually smarter to handle it
like this and we see Ellie getting log which
ends up setting the place on fire in the game
as he went to escape David grabbed you and
eventually this knocked over a lamp which
then started the Blaze and several lines in
the game are pulled directly across here no
way out Ellie the doors are locked and I have
the keys nowhere to go you want out let's
come get these Keys now Ali burning down this
quote-unquote church also symbolically shows
how she's burning down the facade of everything
David spelled the pair battle it out with
one another and the struggle ends up being
exactly like how it is in the game
foreign
[Music]
it's me it's me
yeah I like breaking the
batter it's like bringing Darkness into the
light
[Music]
[Music] it's okay baby girl look at you during
David's death we keep the focus on Ellie and
it shows how much our kill she's giving to
this wicked and evil man shall Comforts her
and we get a really important line dropped
here where he calls her baby girl this is
the same nickname that he gave to Sarah and
at this point he's all in on this being his
daughter the pair woke off together with his
arm around you're my daughter only we're in
episode two after Tessa's death Jill stormed
away leaving Ali Raz here we see them closer
than they've ever been the pair have bonded
over everything and whereas she once was just
cargo here he's putting a card around here
to let her know everything's okay
wait that was this imagery that's often used
in the show and game and it stages the characters
are going on the next part of their Journey
now before we get into the spoiler section
I'll give my review and I thought this episode
was really solid with some great performances
in it Scott Shepard brought a lot to David
at that point he was even creepier than Nolan
North in the game things are are a lot more
implied but there were some extra lines of
dialogue that they added which really freaked
me out now it was also really nice seeing
Troy Baker too and he gave a lot away from
just minor facial expressions Kyle looked
completely beaten up at points and his Meek
performance made me think that he very much
represented the town's citizens who refused
to confront David I think this episode worked
really well as an evolution of Ellie as well
and it's no coincidence that this is the chapter
in the game where you first take control of
her like that section this is very much about
her having to fight to survive without help
from others so far she's relied on people
like Federer Riley Marlene Joel Tess and Henry
and Sam well this is her showing that when
she's cornered she can handle things that
come her way you also see that the character
is realizing that this world isn't as fun
as its cracked up to be going back to the
opening in episode 3 we've seen how she thought
wielding a gun with something cool and also
exciting here though we have his smashing
David's head like it's a like button and we
see the Relentless anger that she carries
a huge change in Dynamic and her growth is
a character now as for what I didn't like
you already know what I'm gonna say and I
think the show has continued to under use
the infected which has taken away from some
of the most memorable scenes of the game I
think if we had something with David where
they had to fight some of them it would have
made that turn as impactful as it is in the
game and with the episode just being 45 minutes
long I think we could have easily have gotten
another 10 or even five minutes where we had
something like that play out I'm guessing
that they pulled back on shiny in fact it
is much because of the budget but every week
it seems like there's a major moment involving
them which is left on The Cutting Room floor
minor nitpick and yeah obviously the game's
there if you want to see more of them but
I did kind of want an action scene like that
with Ellie so we could see what she was capable
of against humans and also the infected and
that takes us into the Super spoiler section
and for the next part of the video I want
to go over some of the Easter eggs that will
probably give the the game away if you don't
want things spoiled then thanks for watching
thanks a lot mate again for wasting 40 minutes
of your life and I hope to see you back for
the finale next week now the first thing I
want to talk about is the interrogation technique
in part two aliors ends up using this and
we of course needed to see her actually see
it for herself in order to explain how she
knows this you also discover that Silver Lake
is oh yeah I wonder if this line was thrown
to show how Resorts have changed across the
country as part 2 ends with Ellie going to
a resort on the hunt for Abby this was controlled
by slavers and you can see how these holiday
locations have been Twisted in this new world
and lastly is Ellie buying David was he infected
was he not we don't fully know however Ellie
does end up kissing Dino in the second game
and at one point she also bites Abby when
she's buying her in the theater as we know
Abby doesn't get infected and thus I don't
think that Ellie's bite actually could infect
people infection seems to have stopped at
her um and not made its way to herself cyber
glands and this I don't think she passes it
on so I don't think Ellie actually infected
David and either she didn't know or she used
it as a weapon rather see she's been told
to hide it from people but she pulls her down
this moment to further slow down confusion
yeah this throws James off a bit and it adds
upon what he was experiencing before allowing
Ali to escape anyway that wraps up the video
and huge thank you for sticking with me until
the end wow are you gonna say he didn't miss
one like the drink I'm surprising to talk
at all about how Joel the person the reason
they want revenge against trolls for killing
the someone who's a father oh yes yes and
then leaving a little girl behind who who
declares She Wants Revenge well he didn't
go in the time machine and watch her reaction
and to know so it was like my main takeaway
with the change was like wow that's a massive
foreshadow yeah I mean that's what that's
what he's got us for I need to message him
like why are you dropping the ball here or
Paul Paul with the drop balls but if if you
noticed on not only the reaction but here
too I don't mind those other action sequences
where like where Ellie was fending off and
just gotta keep defending yourself no I'm
just saying a lot of people think but I'm
going to keep saying the point I'm making
is like I don't mind you getting rid of certain
things yeah thank you I don't mind you getting
rid of certain action it's storytelling action
sequences that I like to be kept it's all
filler um thank you so yeah it's all Phil
or Andrew yeah the show is perfect they never
make a miscalculation nothing is per it's
every episode 10 out of 10 and you're a bigot
if you say otherwise uh yeah specifically
a bigot you're a Last of Us hater you're a
bigot I love that that's so funny anyway Andrew
guys they should subscribe to Paul and we
should also do it Andrew pick any name here
go back down okay we gotta go with David David
Gandy oh that is perfect David is actually
quite a religious person in real life too
so this is this is a wonderful perfect choice
for this David uh yeah David sometimes performs
music uh at his church as well he's a guitarist
he's a man of God God-fearing individual and
now David I think it's about time you take
over that church of yours right now what they
need is a solid preacher they need you to
rise to the ranks I know that sometimes when
we talk to you can sound a little bit meek
and you got this really soft-spoken voice
but that's so you can lure people in make
you seem trustworthy and like oh he's so nice
but David come on man now is your time to
take control of the people at your church
you can get them to do whatever you want Mr
Gandy why are you wasting your time just being
a shepherd and nope wrong word one of the
sheep when you could be the Shepherd come
on dude David what is America without taking
advantage of other people get involved get
in the action man it's all about manipulation
all about manipulation dude all about manipulation
now I gotta clarify for YouTube when I'm being
serious or sarcastic I'm being a hundred percent
serious right now it is Arizona's boring do
something interesting in Arizona start a new
cult
I'm sorry David praise be to God keep your
faith thank you for being a patron of ours
for so long Anthony you want to say David
thank you David I will visit you in church
sometimes if uh my Rabbi says it's okay oh
God I can't wait to eat you with or without
the yamaka on oh with okay perfect with the
Yamaha I've always said in my head if I want
to get eaten it's with Miami con so I appreciate
you at least I just ordered five yamakas off
Amazon
it's a weird video [Music]